[Applause]
this was not a vigil it was an act of
collective anger protesters upset over
the assassination of journalist Daphne
Khurana Galicia called for the
resignation of the island nations police
commissioner
they threw coins at a banner of Lawrence
kütahya chanting shame on you and no
change no justice Galicia was an
investigative journalist who specialized
in corruption cases just before her
death she posted a message saying that
in Malta there were crooks everywhere
she died when a bomb planted in her car
exploded at another rally close by the
capital Valletta people remembered her
passion I would say she was admired and
resented in equal measure
there were a lot of people who couldn't
stand the way she wrote the gossip
element of it especially but in reality
she was one of the ones who really
honored some of the biggest scandals in
recent years others in the crowd say
they want a new Malta we're here because
we want to show that the next generation
and believe in freedom of speech that we
will not be silenced and as we will
always speak out against injustice when
we see it to support freedom of speech
as it's being attacked in the country
right now the leaders of Malta's main
political parties were not in attendance
at either rally one said he knew Galicia
spam Lee did not want him there
under the slogan no change no justice
thousands have gathered here to demand
justice in the ongoing investigations in
the case of the murdered Panama papers
journalist Daphne coruña Galicia some
say it's the biggest protests that Malta
has ever seen